this one concept is making so many of  you unhappy and anxious  that's right let me flip the Hat because  I'm about to get serious  this concept of should [ __ ] up so many  people when I saw this headline I'm like  oh I got a green screen the [ __ ] out of  this because should kills you should for  who should For What whose rules people  are playing into societal rules people  are playing into family Rules people are  playing into the rules of one subjective  opinion in their life there is no should  should actually doesn't exist should is  a problem and so for many of you right  now you're like I should have done this  by 30. I should be like that person  should is based on Envy should is based  on insecurity should is a cancer inside  your emotional framework cut the should  out of your [ __ ] life